c'est l'histoire d'un jeune homme
amoureux un étranger venu de l'ouest
pour lui ravir sa belle alès une
histoire de jalousie qui se solde par un
meurtre tout ça va compter avec un
humour grinçant une formule d'enel
karadzic a le secret 1980 alors que le
punk fait un tabac il a fondé à sarajevo
le groupe a braillé nos poches et nier
le no smoking orchestra en anglais avec
un groupe d'amis
le maréchal tito l'homme fort du pays
socialiste venait de mourir il voulait
bousculer les systèmes l'utopia
oui à ibb au taux change de web guitar
and with you know it choix les chanteurs
et ses comparses n'avait pas tort leur
monde allait être bouleversé la chute du
mur de berlin a précipité la fin des
régimes communistes partout derrière le
rideau de fer
mais le vent de liberté et de démocratie
n'a pas soufflé que du bon my life care
in two days in trop de bugs oui un
effondrement qui est passé par des
années de guerre est un peu à l'image de
la yougoslavie le groupe a braillé nos
couches aigner s'est désintégré peu de
temps avant que de nouvelles frontières
soit tracée dans le centre
neil le serbe s'est retrouvé à belgrade
l'a coupé les ponts avec les autres
membres fondateurs du groupe
10h07 jositsch l'ancien batteur du
groupe a délaissé la musique au profit
de la production télévisuelle à sarajevo
il est devenu célèbre en flirtant avec
les limites de la liberté d'expression
dans un régime totalitaire en fin de vie
mais ils croient aujourd'hui qu'il était
nécessaire imposer certains interdits
puis au le king aux élections 22 11 952
power fument en sorte d'être des stars
non
une autre histoire
[Musique]
la you gonna stade j voilà comment se
nomme ce sentiment partagé par de
nombreux habitants de l'ex yougoslavie à
belgrade comme à sarajevo où on retrouve
des cafés thématiques à la gloire du
pays disparu et de son dirigeant à la
main de fer le temps et la guerre semble
avoir effacé pour beaucoup le maréchal
tito dictateur celui du parti unique de
la répression et des goulags le maréchal
tito a réunifié par la force la
yougoslavie aujourd'hui fragmenté en
sept pays distincts ce faisant il a
interdit les religions sur la place
publique et tout fait les revendications
linguistiques et nationaliste
je vous êtes la brosse à dents le regard
bleu acier quelque chose d'une riche
alti tôt la petite fille de l'ex
dirigeant raconte qu'elle n'aurait
jamais cru possible la guerre entre
voisins elle aussi montre du doigt les
politiciens nationalistes qui ont pris
le pouvoir après les premières élections
libres en ex-yougoslavie des ménages tôt
[Musique]
cardiologue de profession svetlana se
consacre depuis 20 ans à une ong qui
milite pour le développement de la
société civile
elles regrettent le passé mais préfère
regarder devant
elle se montre dur envers ses
compatriotes m 7 pi pour yves nau
[Musique]
le star i must le vieux pont érigé au
xvième siècle dans la toute petite ville
de mostar en bosnie herzégovine ne
trahit plus aucune trace de sa
destruction quasi totale au début des
années 90
[Musique]
le touriste foule de nouveau ses pavés
restaurer avec l'aide de l'unesco
un symbole de la fin d'une guerre
fratricide mais les graines de la
discorde et de la haine qui ont mené à
ces ruines aux mains des forces croates
sont toujours en semences et aujourd'hui
d'un login au grade de rajouter la gr
d'impôt de grillades ferrata talbot jt
wyman tchaï karachi sud rapporte aux
motards ou gisèle ory nam hong kong robe
le néo promu en top 14 et mouslim année
il prévoit soir ni yoni qu il soit et
c'est milan shehadé tony forme un
improbable trio dans la ville le serbe
le bosniaque et le croate veulent punir
les jeunes de leurs trois communautés à
travers des projets culturels comme le
théâtre ce genre d'initiative
personnelle fait difficilement le poids
face à une extrême droite bien active en
politique
de retour en serbie le kiosque de
vojislav seselj relais jeunes
ultra-nationalistes virulent a été
condamné pour crimes de guerre par le
tribunal pénal pour l'ex-yougoslavie
une condamnation qui n'empêche en rien
de siéger au parlement et de militer
pour son projet d'une grande serbie 1 0
sochaux 1re stg
destroy ces violences de mardi à
mercredi à milan maicon sens bat wang
bing maps
ces genres de discours qui plaît à mylan
un jeune étudiant en médecine qui fait
écho aux propos de son modèle politique
et que ce soit et ce big mistake
oui guichen conscience en irlande en des
mycoses
qu'un pays de l'ex yougoslavie ne s'est
à ce jour prêté un exercice commun de
mémoire pour exorciser les démons de la
guerre
pas de vérité et réconciliation ici à
chacun ses blessures à chacun ses
traumas et son interprétation de
l'histoire au risque peut-être dans
répéter les moments de plus on